Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishist the day that England are playing Wales. And I think it's time for a sing-song. MUSIC PLAYS That was the opening verse of Amma Ahid by David Iffon. It's become very much the kind of the great theme for Welsh football. I'm sure it'll be sung on the terraces this afternoon. And Dominic, I will give you, because I'm assuming that your mastery of Welsh
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishist 恰逢英格兰对阵威尔士的日子。我想是时候来一首合唱了。音乐响起 这是大卫·伊冯（David Iffon）演唱的《阿马·阿希德》（Amma Ahid）的开场诗。这首歌已经很大程度上成为了威尔士足球的伟大主题曲。我相信今天下午球迷看台一定会高歌这首歌。多米尼克，我给你一个机会，因为我猜你对威尔士语的精通程度
isn't up to understanding what was being sung there, but maybe I'm wrong. Am I wrong? The podcast listeners know me, Tom, as the master of tongues. The master of tongues. Well, for those whose Welsh may not enable them to translate it.
可能还不足以听懂刚才唱的是什么，不过也许我猜错了。我猜错了吗？听播客的朋友们都知道我，汤姆，我是语言大师。语言大师。好吧，对于那些可能无法将其翻译出来的威尔士语爱好者来说。
Let me just quickly distance myself from your Welsh pronunciation. Just for the... Okay. Yeah. I just want to put that absolutely on the record. That's fine. Please continue. That's fine.
我只想赶紧把我自己和你的威尔士语发音撇清关系。只是为了……好吧。是的。我只想把这一点绝对记录在案。没关系。请继续。没关系。
You are from Shropshire. You are entitled to say that. So the meaning of the words, you don't remember Maxim. Nobody knows him. 1,600 years, a time too long to remember when Magnus Maximus left Wales in the year 383, leaving us a whole nation. And today, look at us. So I think that is a magnificent sentiment. Firstly, because as far as I know, it's the only football anthem that mentions the Roman emperor. But secondly, Dominic, when he says
你是什罗普郡人。你有资格这么说。所以这些词的意思是，你不记得马克西姆了。没有人认识他。1600年，时间太久，让人记不清马格努斯·马克西姆（Magnus Maximus）在公元383年离开威尔士、给我们留下一个完整国家时的情景了。而今天，看看我们。所以我认为这是一种宏伟的情怀。首先，据我所知，这是唯一一首提到罗马皇帝的足球赞歌；但其次，多米尼克，当他说
that nobody knows him, that's not true. Because regular listeners to The Rest is History will remember Magnus Maximus, because we did an episode on the ghostly afterlife of the Roman Empire. We did, yes. And we talked about how the Welsh princes over the early Middle Ages and into the final extinction of Welsh independence under Edward I, that they preserved this memory that they were kind of descended from, they had this Roman lineage, that they were princes by virtue of having been appointed to their rank by Magnus Maximus, who is this Roman general who stripped the island of its legions and went to Gaul and perished. And so that sense of the Welsh as a Roman people in opposition to the English who
没有人认识他，这并非事实。因为《The Rest is History》的忠实听迷都会记得马格努斯·马克西姆，因为我们做过一期关于罗马帝国幽灵般的前世今生的节目。是的，我们做过。我们讨论了威尔士诸侯在早中世纪以及在爱德华一世统治下威尔士独立最终消亡的过程中，如何保留了这样一种记忆：他们似乎是某种后裔，他们有着罗马血统，他们之所以成为诸侯，是因为被任命为这一阶层的马格努斯·马克西姆——这位将该岛的军团抽空并前往高卢最终丧命的罗马将军——所赋予。因此，威尔士人作为一个罗马民族、与作为
were barbarians was very strong. You made an incredible claim at the end of that episode, didn't you? That the last Roman emperor was Prince Charles, as he then was. Because the argument was that Edward I, when he appoints his son, the future Edward II, as Prince of Wales, is kind of appropriating that tradition. And it's been handed down through the heirs of the British monarch right the way to the present day. And of course, there is a slight tension in the role played by the current Prince of Wales, who is Prince William, who's always been very, very out and proud as an England football fan. Yeah, there's been lots of controversy about this in recent days, Tom, because quite a few welsh fans the actor michael sheen prominent among them have been lambasting him and saying how can you be prince of
蛮族的英格兰人相对立的这种意识非常强烈。你在那期节目的末尾提出了一个令人难以置信的观点，不是吗？那就是最后一个罗马皇帝其实就是当时的查尔斯王子。因为当时的论点是，爱德华一世在任命他的儿子、未来的爱德华二世为威尔士亲王时，某种程度上是在借用这一传统。并且这一传统一直通过英国君主的继承人代代相传，直到今天。当然，现任威尔士亲王威廉王子所扮演的角色中存在着一丝紧张关系，他一直非常公开且毫不掩饰地表现出自己是一名英格兰足球迷。是的，汤姆，最近几天关于这件事有很多争议，因为相当多的威尔士球迷——演员麦克·辛（Michael Sheen）就是其中的杰出代表——一直在猛烈抨击他，说你怎么能既是威尔士亲王又支持英格兰呢？而他那种经典的温莎式的“和稀泥”做法就是说：我两边都支持，我希望他们两个都能进决赛，然后我再作决定，我希望他们俩都能赢。不过，汤姆，我们成功做出了我们的经典操作，对吧？我们聊了快五分钟，甚至都没提到那位一直坐在那儿等待的嘉宾。我们有一位非常棒的嘉宾。非常、非常耐心。所以我们确实有一位很棒的嘉宾。
wales and be supporting england and his sort of you know classic house of winds of fudge is to say i'm supporting both i hope they both make it to the final and then i'll decide and i hope they both win but tom uh we have managed to do our classic thing, haven't we? We're talking for almost five minutes without even mentioning the guest who's been sitting waiting. We have a brilliant guest. Very, very patiently. So we do have a brilliant guest.
正如你所解释的，今天的主题是威尔士。什么是威尔士？什么是威尔士精神（Welshness）？它又是如何通过与英格兰相对立来定义自己的？这绝对是今天这场比赛的完美主题。我们也有最完美的嘉宾。他是斯旺西大学的历史学教授马丁·琼斯（Martin Jones），也是《威尔士：英格兰的殖民地》（Wales, England's Colony）一书的作者。
The subject today, as you've explained, is Wales. What is Wales? What is Welshness? And how does it define itself against England? The perfect subject for today's match. And we have the perfect guest. He is Martin Jones, Professor of History at the University of Swansea, and the author of the book, Wales, England's Colony.
是的，这个问号非常重要。马丁，欢迎来到《The Rest is History》。威尔士，英格兰的殖民地，还是并非如此？这取决于我们讨论的是什么时候。我不会用“殖民地”这个词来形容今天的威尔士，但如果你追溯到中世纪时期，我认为我们无法否认威尔士曾遭到军事征服，并受制于将威尔士人置于特定地位的殖民地法律。他们在自己的国家里是二等公民。
Yes, the question mark is very important. So Martin, welcome to The Rest is History. Wales, England's Colony, or not? It depends when we're talking about. I wouldn't use the term to describe Wales today as a colony, but certainly if you go back to the medieval period, I don't think we can deny that Wales was militarily conquered and subject to colonial laws that put the Welsh in their place. They were second-class citizens in their own nation.
因此，如果你想追溯到那么久以前，我认为把威尔士称为英格兰的第一个殖民地是可以接受的。没错。所以当我们审视英格兰和威尔士之间的关系时，贯穿你这本书的主题之一是：在那段关系的大部分历史中，威尔士一直在通过与英格兰相对立来定义自己，而英格兰却没有通过与威尔士相对立来定义自己。完全正确。我的意思是，威尔士是一个非常小的国家。今天它有310万人口，在其整个历史中，它的政治、文化和经济一直生活在英格兰的阴影之下。你甚至可以说，将威尔士的不同部族、不同的中世纪
So I think if you want to go that far back, I think it's fine to call Wales maybe England's first colony. Right. And so when we look at the relationship between England and Wales, one of the themes that runs throughout your book is that for most of the history of that relationship, Wales has defined itself against England, whereas England has not defined itself against Wales. Exactly. I mean, Wales is a very small nation. Today it's 3.1 million people and throughout its history, its politics, its culture, its economy has existed in the shadow of England. And you could argue that one of the things that brought the different peoples of Wales together, the different medieval
王国凝聚在一起的原因之一，就是对英格兰的差异感。你可以说，正是当那些剥夺了威尔士人在自己国家中公民权利的法律通过之后，他们才开始在彼此身上感受到某种共同点。波伊斯（Powys）和圭内德（Gwynedd）的人民发展出了共同的身份认同。这并不罕见。这在历史上屡见不鲜。人们通过与一个庞大的邻国相对立来定义自己。不幸的是，有时这会导致我们内心带有一点自卑情结，或许作为一个国家没能表现出应有的自信。如今在威尔士政治中，许多争论都围绕着如何超越这一点，为了威尔士性（Welshness）本身而享受它，
kingdoms, was a sense of difference to England. You could argue that it was only once those laws that were passed that denied the Welsh civil rights in their own country that they began to feel something in common with each other. The people of Powys and Gwynedd developed a common identity. This isn't unusual. This happens across history. People define themselves against a large neighbour. The unfortunate thing is that sometimes that can lead to us having a slight chip on our shoulder, maybe not being as confident as we should be as a nation. Today in Welsh politics, a lot of the argument is about moving beyond that and enjoying Welshness for its own sake,
而不仅仅是因为它与英格兰不同。所以“威尔士”这个名字本身，其实是一个从外部强加给威尔士的名字，对吧？它的意思是陌生人、局外人或外国人。这是由英国人强加的名字。我说的对吗？我的意思是，“强加”暗示着有人走过来对你说“你必须接受这个名字”，而实际情况并非如此。这个名字的起源非常复杂。我的意思是，当我们追溯到那么久远的过去时，很难确切知道这些词当时的含义。而且它在不同的语境中似乎有不同的含义。但它的核心是一种差异感、他者感。这个名字是被盎格鲁-撒克逊人赋予我们现在所称的威尔士的人民的，
rather than just because it's different to England. So the very name Wales, that's a name imposed on Wales from outside, right? It means the strangers or the others or the foreigners. And that's a name imposed by the English. Am I right? I mean, imposed suggests that somebody's coming along and saying, you must take this name, and that isn't happening. The origins of the name are very difficult. I mean, when we're going that far back, it's difficult to know exactly what words meant. And it seems to have different meanings in different contexts. But at its heart is a sense of difference, of otherness. And that name is given to the people of what we now call Wales by the Anglo-Saxons,
尽管我猜这个词在各方面都具有争议性。在这个播客里可不争。在这个播客里不争。所以这确实把我们带回了英格兰的起源、关于英格兰人的概念。传统的说法是，威尔士人最初将自己定义为不列颠人。他们是不列颠的土著居民。绝对是这样。而且威尔士人是不列颠人这种意识在早期威尔士历史中非常重要。在威尔士历史中存在着一种强烈的失落感，即他们曾是这座岛屿的主人，然后这些日耳曼人来到这里并从他们手中夺走了它。在威尔士历史中，
although I suppose that's a controversial term in various ways. Not in this podcast. Not in this podcast. So it does take us back to the beginnings of England, the idea of the English. And the traditional story is that the Welsh initially defined themselves as Britons. They are the indigenous inhabitants of Britain. Absolutely. And that sense that the Welsh are British is really important in early Welsh history. There is a strong sense of loss in Welsh history that once they were the owners of this island and then these Germanic peoples came and took it from them. And within Welsh history,
在威尔士传说中，有一个非常强烈的观点：总有一天会有人回来，将我们从英格兰的统治下解放出来，把这座岛屿还给我们。这种“预言之子”（Amabdorogan）的概念被应用到了欧文·格林杜尔（Owen Glyndŵr）反抗英格兰统治的中世纪起义中。但它也被应用到了亨利七世（Henry VII）、亨利·都铎（Henry Tudor）身上，他拥有一些威尔士血统。当他登上英格兰王位、在博斯沃思战役后夺取王权时，威尔士产生了一种感觉：这代表着威尔士现在重新夺回了对其岛屿的控制权。当亨利七世成为国王时，他在自己的皇家纹章中加入了红龙。这可以说是——如果你想以神话形式表达撒克逊人与不列颠人、英格兰人与威尔士人之间冲突的故事，经典的版本是梅林（Merlin）得到一个预言：一条红龙和一条白龙在互相搏斗，最终红龙将白龙
within Welsh legends, there is a very strong idea that one day someone will come back and liberate us from English rule and give us back the island. That idea of sort of the son of prophecy, Amabdorogan, is applied to Owen Glyndŵr in his medieval uprisings against English rule. But it's also applied to Henry VII, Henry Tudor, who had some Welsh ancestry. And when he comes to the English throne, when he takes it after the Battle of Rosworth, there is a sense in Wales that this is Wales now taking back control of their island. And when Henry VII becomes king, he adds to his royal arms the red dragon. And that is the kind of the archetype of, If you want to express the story of the conflict between Saxons and Britons, English and Welsh in mythic form, the classic account is that Merlin is told of a vision of a red and a white dragon fighting one another, and that in the end, the red dragon chases the white dragon
赶跑了。梅林说红龙代表威尔士或不列颠人，白龙代表撒克逊人.据推测，从长远来看，这暗示着威尔士人将把现在被称为英格兰的土地夺回来。是的。在许多方面，这些故事对威尔士文化至关重要，一直延续到今天，因为它们向威尔士人表明：面对英格兰的征服、面对英格兰的压迫，如果这么说的话，他们依然是一个国家。历史赋予了威尔士人一个更好的故事，一个充满自信的故事，一个乐观的故事，一个让他们感到自己是一个民族的故事。因此，多年来，历史对于维持威尔士的民族意识起到了至关重要的作用。而这种坚韧不拔的精神也非常重要。我的意思是，你在播客开头提到的那首歌《Amal Hid》，你知道的，它的翻译
off. Merlin says that the red dragon is Wales or the Britons, and that the white dragon is the Saxons. Presumably, the implication of that in the long run is that the Welsh will get what's now England back. Yeah. These stories are really important in Welsh culture right up to the present day in many ways, because they tell the Welsh that they're a nation in the face of English conquest, in the face of English oppression, if you want to put it that way. History gave the Welsh a better story, a story that was confident, a story that was optimistic, a story that made them feel that they were a people. So history has been really important in kind of sustaining a sense of Welsh nationhood over the years. And that idea of perseverance is really important. I mean, the song you mentioned at the beginning of the podcast, Amal Hid, you know, translates
就是“依然在”.这首歌的核心信息其实并不是关于马克西姆和罗马皇帝的。它是关于威尔士身份如何在岁月中存活下来的，正如歌词所说，尽管历经所有人、历经一切，我们依然在这里。历史是威尔士身份的核心所在。关于我们在学校里教授的本国历史是否足够、教授威尔士历史是否具有政治性、它是否通往独立的途径，这些都极具争议。但在威尔士，历史被政治化了，其程度或许是英格兰所不及的。不过那种身份认同、那种威尔士身份确实经历了一番演变，不是吗？因为同样，一直追溯到最初，在诺曼人到来之前，正是一个统一王国在日后成为英格兰的土地上的崛起，基本把威尔士人挤压到了角落里。因为英格兰的土地比多山的威尔士土地要富饶得多。这意味着必然存在权力上的差距，而这大概为随后一千年的关系定下了基调。
as still here. And the whole message of that song is not really about Maxen and Roman emperors. It's about how Welsh identity has survived through the years, as the song says, despite everyone and despite everything, we are still here. And history is so central to Welsh identity. And it's really controversial about whether we teach enough of our history in our schools, whether teaching Welsh history is political, whether it's a route to independence. But history is politicised in Wales and in ways that maybe it's not so much in England. But that identity, that Welsh identity has definitely kind of evolved, hasn't it? Because again, going right back to the beginning, so before the arrival of the Normans, it's the emergence of a unitary kingdom in what becomes England that basically pens the Welsh in. Because the land of England is so much richer than the more mountainous land of Wales. It means that there's an inevitable discrepancy of power, which presumably has then set the balance of the relationship for the thousand years that followed.
是的，我认为地理对中世纪历史非常重要。群山是诺曼人在征服英格兰后没有大规模挺进威尔士的原因之一。虽然有诺曼人的入侵，他们夺取了低地地区，但群山很难进入，而且实际攻占它们的收益也较少。那里其实没有太多东西。因此，群山延缓了英格兰人对威尔士的入侵，但同时也把威尔士变成了一座某种意义上的堡垒。这帮助威尔士身份得以存续。这种状态在随后的几个世纪里也一直延续下来，直到18世纪的浪漫主义者开始将威尔士视为一个美丽的地方。它是一个粗犷、危险、崎岖的地方。英格兰
Yeah, geography is really important, I think, to medieval history. The mountains are one reason why maybe there wasn't the big push by the Normans into Wales after they take England. There are Norman incursions, they take low land areas, but the mountains were difficult to access, but also there's less reward for actually taking them. There's not a lot actually there. So the mountains sort of slow the English incursion into Wales, but it also turns Wales into something of a fortress, if you like. And that helps Welsh identity survive. And that survives down in the subsequent centuries as well, until the romantics of the 18th century start thinking of Wales as a beautiful place. It's a rough, dangerous, rugged place. And there's simply little reason for English
游客根本没有什么理由去那里。这就保护了威尔士的身份和威尔士语。所以此时我们正在谈论威尔士身份、威尔士语、威尔士。其中有多少东西是时代错置的（anachronistic），你知道的，是我们这些21世纪的人或20世纪的人强行投射回过去的观念？换句话说，11世纪或12世纪的人，会认为自己是威尔士人吗？会觉得自己是南北贯通、说一种语言、拥有同一文化的同一民族吗？我的意思是，他们绝对不会认为自己是凯尔特人，对吧？
visitors to go there. And that protects Welsh identity and the Welsh language. So at this point we're talking about Welsh identity, the Welsh language, Wales. How much of those things are anachronistic, you know, concepts that we in the 21st century or people in the 20th century were projecting backwards? So in other words, would people in the 11th century or whatever, or the 12th century, would they have thought of themselves as Welsh, as being one people from north to south, speaking one language with one culture? I mean, they definitely wouldn't have thought of themselves as Celts, would they?
因为我猜那同样是一个更现代的发明。是的，凯尔特人，我其实非常不喜欢“凯尔特”这个词，尽管它在威尔士被广泛使用。它是具有误导性的。如果你回到中世纪，显然很难知道普通人、也就是农民的想法，因为根本没有人问过他们，也没有人把它写下来。但威尔士的领主们似乎确实有强烈的威尔士意识。他们确实在谈论威尔士语、威尔士文化。
Because that, again, is a more modern invention, I guess. Yeah, Celts, I really don't like the term Celtic, although it's used quite a lot in Wales. It's misleading. If you go back to the Middle Ages, it's really obviously difficult to know what ordinary people, what peasants thought, because simply nobody asked them and nobody wrote it down. But the lords of Wales do seem to have had a sense of Welshness. They do talk about Welsh language, about the Welsh culture.
威尔士各个王国的诸侯们都在谈论威尔士身份。他们结盟对抗英格兰人或诺曼人。在统治阶级中间，似乎确实存在一种威尔士意识。它与来自波伊斯、圭内德、代赫巴思（Deheabarth）或任何其他威尔士王国的意识共存。但似乎共同的语言和共同的法律确实赋予了威尔士人一种身份认同感，以及与边境另一侧的英格兰人截然不同的感觉。所以你在你那本精彩的书《Wales, England's Colony》中，引用了圣大卫（St. David's）第一任诺曼主教的话，他形容威尔士人在民族、
The princes of the various kingdoms of Wales talk about Welshness. They make alliances against the English or against the Normans. And it does seem that amongst the ruling class, there is a sense of Welshness. It coexists alongside a sense of being from Powys or Gwynedd or Deheabarth or any of the other Welsh kingdoms. But it does seem to be that a common language and a common law as well do give the Welsh a sense of identity and a sense of difference to the English on the other side of the border. So you, in your wonderful book, Wales, England's Colony, you quote the first Norman Bishop of St. David's as saying of the Welsh that they are entirely different in nation,
语言、法律、习惯、判断和习俗上都完全不同。我假设这是指与英格兰人、诺曼人或整个拉丁欧洲的总体作对比。我的意思是，他是在和谁比较？我的意思是，英格兰人和诺曼人在这个时期往往混为一谈，对吧？而且，有时很难区分究竟是在对谁说话。但确实存在那种关于习俗不同的异族的感觉。而且重要的是要记住，这一时期的民族不仅仅被视为某种政治单位。它关乎我们今天所说的种族。因为说到政治联合，实际上只有一个八年的时期，不是吗？
language, laws and habits, judgments and customs. Presume that is with reference to the English or to the Normans or to the totality of kind of Latin Europe. I mean, who's he comparing them to? I mean, sort of the English and the Normans get mixed up in this period, don't they? And, you know, it's sometimes hard to distinguish between who's exactly been spoken to about. But there is that sense of, you know, other people with habits. And it's important to think that, you know, nationhood in this period isn't just seen as kind of political units. It's about what we today would call race. Because on the topic of political union, really, there's only an eight-year period, isn't there,
当时存在的是一个统一的威尔士民族，而不是一堆不同的威尔士封建领地。是的，威尔士被划分为不同的王国。它们不断地互相征战。它们不断争夺控制权，哪个王国最强大在几个世纪的进程中不断起伏。但是的，只有一个八年的时期，你可以说威尔士所有的王国都在一个统治者之下。但这并不意味着不存在威尔士作为一个民族、作为一个整体的意识，不存在某种共同血统的意识。这就是我们回归这个观点的地方：曾经整个岛屿都是我们的，我们是不列颠真正的正统，而盎格鲁-撒克逊人来
where there is a kind of Welsh nation rather than a collection of different principalities that are all Welsh. Yeah, Wales is divided up into different kingdoms. They're constantly at war with each other. They're constantly vying for control, which one's most powerful ebbs and flows over the course of the centuries. But yeah, there is only an eight-year period where you could say all of the kingdoms of Wales are under one ruler. But that doesn't mean that there isn't this sense of the Welsh as a nation, as a people, that there isn't some sense of a common ancestry. And that's where we go back to this idea that once this was our whole island, and we are the true Britons, and the Anglo-Saxons came and
并从我们手中夺走了它，现在诺曼人又来从我们手中夺走了它。但总有一天我们会卷土重来。所以那个国王是格鲁菲德·阿普·卢埃林（Gruffudd ap Llywelyn），他是诺曼征服之前的国王。正如诺曼征服对英格兰人来说是一次痛苦的经历一样，对威尔士人来说，当然也显然是一次非常痛苦的经历。诺曼人来到不列颠对威尔士人、威尔士身份以及政治意义上威尔士性的连贯性产生了什么影响？嗯，早期的诺曼领主在威尔士几乎拥有自由裁量权的权力。你知道，这些男爵有机会在威尔士建立几乎类似于私人企业的东西。英格兰王室几乎等同于说：你们在那里想干什么就干什么。渐渐地，个别的男爵、个别的诺曼领主在威尔士占领土地。这些就是边境区（marches）。所以这是在边境区之前形成的吗？
took it from us, and now the Normans have come and taken it from us. But one day we will return. So that king is Graffitap Llywelyn, who is a king just before the Norman conquest. And just as the Norman conquest is a traumatic experience for the English, so also, of course, is it clearly a very traumatic experience for the Welsh. And what is the impact of the coming of the Normans to Britain on the Welsh, on Welsh identity and on the coherence of a kind of political sense of Welshness? Well, the early Norman lords are almost given a free reign in Wales. You know, there is an opportunity for these barons to kind of set up almost like private enterprises in Wales. The English crown almost says, do what you want over there. And gradually, individual barons, individual Norman lords take land within Wales. So these are the marches. So it comes before the marches.
是的。这就创造了我们所说的边境区，这是一种基本上处于诺曼统治之下的边缘地区。因此，对威尔士的征服在征服英格兰之后不久就开始了。这改变了威尔士的整个政治格局，因为突然之间，你的家门口出现了一个强大的敌人，它在军事上更优越，拥有更好的资源，而且非常难被击败。我认为，这在现存的威尔士王国之间产生了一种团结感。但它们也成了一种盟友，威尔士王国可以在彼此的战斗和敌对状态中利用这种盟友关系。因此，不仅是威尔士的政治，整个岛屿的政治都被诺曼征服改变了。我喜欢所有这些，因为我是从边境区来的，马丁，作为一个什罗普郡男孩。所以我是在
Yeah. And that creates what we call the marches, this kind of border area, which is essentially under Norman rule. So the conquest of Wales begins very quickly after the conquest of England. And that changes the whole politics of Wales, because suddenly there's this big foe on your doorstep, which is militarily superior, which has better resources, which is very difficult to beat. And that creates some sense of unity, I think, between the existing Welsh kingdoms. But they also become an ally, which the Welsh kingdoms can use in their battles and rivalries between each other. So the whole politics of not just Wales, but of the whole island is changed by the Norman conquest. I love all this because I'm from the Marches, Martin, as a Shropshire boy. So I grew up in
这样一种环境中长大的：威尔士就在地平线的那头，在长米德（Long Mynd）的山脊那边，风景中点缀着城堡。我其实想问一个关于城堡的问题，因为我猜这一时期及以后建造的城堡是威尔士最著名的由人工建造的地标。当然，你知道，人们今天绕着它们参观，像桑德布鲁克（Sandbrook）家族这样的人会去买印有龙图案的剑和盾牌之类的东西，并且真的非常喜欢它们。但它们是象征，我的意思是，它们真的是压迫的象征，对吧？
this sort of, Wales was just over the horizon, on the other side of the Long Mind and the landscape studded with castles. And I actually wanted to ask a question about castles because I guess the castles that were built in this period and afterwards are the most celebrated man-made landmarks that stand in Wales. But of course, you know, people walk around them today and people like the Sandbrook family go and buy swords and shields of dragons on and whatnot and really love it. But they are symbols of, I mean, they really are symbols of oppression, aren't they?
是监视、控制、外国统治的象征。还是说我太严厉了？这正是它们存在的字面意义。最早的城堡非常小，其目的是将诺曼人的权力植入当地。但最后的那些城堡，也就是由爱德华一世建造的城堡，它们是世界上最宏伟的中世纪建筑结构之一。我认为合理的说法是，从军事角度来看，它们的规模远远超出了实际需要。很难回避这样的结论：它们具有象征意义。
Of surveillance, of control, of foreign domination. Or am I being too harsh? That's what they're literally there for. The very first ones are quite small and they're to kind of implant Norman power over local areas. But the last ones, the ones built by Edward I, they are amongst the grandest medieval structures probably anywhere in the world. And I think it's reasonable to say they are far larger than was actually needed from a military point of view. It's very difficult to escape the conclusion that they are symbolic.
它们在告诉威尔士人：你们是被征服的人民。但或许不仅仅是告诉威尔士人这一点，也是在提醒其他英格兰领主：看一看英格兰王室的权力吧，我们能够建造这样的建筑。因此，它们的象征意义具有双重效果。而且在之后的历史中，它留下了与这些城堡非常复杂的关系。因为一方面，它们提醒威尔士人他们是被征服的人民，提醒他们这段非常艰难的历史。但它们的规模和体量在某种程度上也带来了一些安慰，因为这也是一个提醒：我们曾经很难被击败。而且它们也是巨大的摇钱树，对吧？我的意思是，它们带来了大量的游客。是的，而且它们也是巨大的摇钱树，对吧？我的意思是，
They are telling the Welsh people, you are a conquered people. But maybe not just telling the Welsh people that, but also maybe reminding other English lords, look at the power of the crown, the English crown, that we can build these structures. So the symbolism of them works two ways. And it's left a very complicated relationship with those castles, you know, through the rest of history. Because at one level, they remind the Welsh that there are conquered people, that they remind them of this very difficult history. But the size of them and the scale of them is also something comforting in some ways, because it's also a reminder we were difficult to beat. And they're also big money spinners, right? I mean, they bring in a lot of tourists. Yeah And they're also big money spinners, right? I mean,
它们带来了大量的游客。是的，它们对我们的旅游业大有裨益。而且，你知道，但其中一个遗憾往往是，当你参观它们时，你并没有真正感受到它们背后的政治意境。你知道，这些叙事被严重去政治化了。当然，威尔士和英格兰之间的关系在今天依然在继续。并且人们并没有真正努力去建立与今天的这种联系。所以最著名的城堡全都是由爱德华一世建造的，他完成了对威尔士的征服。他的“铁环”。他的“铁环”。是的，他的“铁环”。你在书中指出，促成征服威尔士的原因之一是英格兰国王失去了他们在
they bring in a lot of tourists. Yeah, they're great for our tourism. And, you know, but one of the shames is often that actually when you walk around them, you don't really get a sense of the politics behind them. You know, it's very depoliticised, the narratives. And of course, the relationship between Wales and England is still happening today. And there isn't really any effort made to make that connection with today. So the most famous castles of all are those that are built by Edward I, who completes the conquest of Wales. His ring of iron. His ring of iron. Yes, his ring of iron. And you make the point in the book that one of the things that prompts the conquest of Wales is the fact that the kings of England have lost their lands
诺曼底的土地。因此他们现在正在寻找可以大显身手的其他舞台。所以威尔士就挡在了这个庞然大物的路上。但你也给出了一个惊人的统计数据：在1287年，在爱德华一世统治下，全威尔士四分之一的成年男性人口都在爱德华的军队中服役。所以这大概不仅仅关于压迫。这也是为了给威尔士人，或者至少是威尔士内部的某些阶层，提供在新政权中的利益攸关地位。当任何国家、任何地方被征服时，总会有当地人去适应他们所面临的政治现实。那些可能在诺曼
in Normandy. And so they now are looking for alternative theatres to kind of throw their weight in. And so Wales is in the way of the juggernaut. But you also give the extraordinary statistic that in 1287, under Edward I, a quarter of the entire Welsh male population was serving in Edward's army. So presumably it's not just about oppression. It's also about giving the Welsh, or at least elements within Wales, a stake within the new regime. When any nation, when any place is conquered, there are always local people who work with the political realities that they are faced with. Those as probably Welsh peasants serving in the Norman
军队中服役的威尔士农民，他们对此有什么选择吗？比起试图靠土地维生，这可能是一份薪水不错的工作。如果你突然变成了一个被征服的人民，加入征服者就是获得某种地位的一种方式。这也是一种生存之道。而且我认为我们回首过去并以黑白分来看待这些事情可能存在危险。这并非诺曼人或英格兰人与威尔士人的对立，因为当时人们的生活现实要复杂得多。我的意思是，在中世纪，仅仅是在大自然面前求生、种植足够的食物、照顾好家庭，这些事情都不是容易的。而且就这些人而言，他们说威尔士语，对吧？他们不说英语。此时有人说英语吗？在早期的诺曼入侵中，人们努力植入基本上是新的人口，即定居者人口。这发生在斯旺西附近的下古尔（Gower），也发生在西南威尔士的南彭布罗克郡（South Pembrokeshire）。这些地方今天仍然高度英格里化。如果你看一看这些地区的地图，地名都是英语的。你知道，这几乎就像字面意义上威尔士人被从地图上抹去了。
army, did they have any choice about the matter? It's a well-paid job probably, you know, compared to trying to live off the land. If you've suddenly become a conquered people, joining the conqueror is a way of maybe getting some status. It's a way of survival. And I think there is a danger maybe of us looking back and thinking of these things in black and white. This is Norman or English versus Welsh, whereas the realities of life for people were quite different. I mean, just survival in the medieval period against the elements, growing enough food, looking after your family, none of these things were easy. And just on these people, they spoke Welsh, right? They didn't speak English. Are there people speaking English at this point? In the early Norman incursions, there are efforts to implant essentially new populations, settler populations. That happens in Gower near Swansea, and that happens in South Pembrokeshire in Southwest Wales. And those places today are still very anglicized. If you look at a map of those areas, the place names are English. You know, it's almost like literally the Welsh have been wiped off the map.
现在，原住民（用一个更好的词来形容）发生了什么，很难知道。他们是被赶出自己的土地了吗？那里原本相对空旷吗？你知道，这里是否发生了某种甚至可以说是种族灭绝的过程？嗯，这和困扰后罗马时期低地不列颠发生之事的那些问题完全一样。我的意思是，这真的非常迷人。但对于威尔士语使用者来说，在英格兰征服完成后，统治他们的法律框架是什么？首先，这与语言无关。我的意思是，你知道，身为威尔士人从未由语言来定义。本质上，语言是身为威尔士人的一个标志，但它被视为一种族裔身份。所以这是一种公开的种族划分吗？是的，绝对是。而且一些威尔士人曾试图将自己定义为英格兰人。他们去地方法院说：哦，不，看看我的血统。尽管我的名字是这样的，
Now, what happened to the indigenous population, for want of a better term, is very difficult to know. Were they forced off their land? Was it relatively empty? You know, is there some kind of process of maybe even genocide going on? Well, it's exactly the same questions as haunt the question of what happens in Lowland Britain in the post-Roman period. I mean, it's really fascinating. But for Welsh speakers, what are the legal frameworks
但我其实是英格兰人。因为他们遭受了法律限制。因为那样能赋予你法律权利。所以当时通过了法律，剥夺了威尔士人携带武器、在城镇居住、在某些地方经商的权利。这些法律并不总是得到严格执行。在某些情况下，它们只是写在成文法典中。历史学家翻阅了租户和居住在威尔士城镇的人的名单，实际上表明其中相当一部分人
that are governing them following the completion of the English conquest? It's not about language, first of all. I mean, you know, being Welsh is never defined by language. In essence, language was a sign of being Welsh, but it is seen as an ethnic identity. So it's kind of overtly racial then? Yeah, absolutely. And there are attempts by some Welsh people to define themselves as English. They go to local courts and say, oh no, look at my heritage. Despite my name,
在某些地方确实拥有威尔士名字。但这些法律确实存在于法典中。这使他们字面意义上成为了二等公民。即便这些法律并不总是得到执行，它们也总是作为背景存在。因此，如果你和邻居闹翻了，你知道的，你酿的啤酒比他好，而且，你知道，你的邻居可能会说：但等一下，你是威尔士人，你甚至不应该在这个镇上，你知道的，这种背景似乎确实存在。我认为说人们在自己的国家里字面意义上是二等公民并不过分。而且他们没有，他们在英格兰议会中没有代表权？他们在英格兰议会中没有代表权。他们在英格兰议会中没有代表权。
I'm actually English. Because they're suffering legal restrictions. Because that gave you legal rights. So there are laws passed that denied the Welsh the ability to carry arms, to live in towns, to trade in certain places. These aren't always enforced. In some cases, they're just on the stature book. And historians have gone through the lists of tenants and people living in Welsh towns and actually shown a fair proportion of
要在阶梯上往上爬可能会很困难。当然，任何国家的治理都需要人，需要会说当地方言的官员。因此，对于威尔士士绅中有抱负的人来说，存在着机遇和职业发展的机会。所以最后还有一次伟大的民族起义，那就是在欧文·格林杜尔领导下的起义。格林杜尔。哦，抱歉，我在扮演莎士比亚戏剧《亨利四世》第一部分里的角色，
them in some places do have Welsh names. But these laws are there on the books. And that made them people literally second-class citizens. And even if these laws aren't always enforced, they're always there in the background. So if you fall out with your neighbour, you know, and you're making better beer than him, and, you know, your neighbour might say, but hang on, you're Welsh, you shouldn't even be in this town, you know, and there does seem to be that in the background. I don't think it's too far to say that people were literally second-class citizens in their own nation. And they don't, there's no representation in the English Parliament? There's no representation in the English Parliament. There's no representation in the English Parliament.
因为他是莎士比亚版《亨利四世》统治时期中的一个人物。对他的描绘太糟糕了，不是吗？因为他就像一个在威尔士语中胡言乱语的某种死灵法师。他说着非常辞藻华丽的诗句，不是吗？是的，是的。哈里· Hotspur（哈里·热刺）对发出嘲讽。我不认为这是一场制作。这是一场在卡菲利（Caerphilly）或诸如此类的街头受欢迎的莎士比亚制作。
It can be difficult to work your way up the ladder. But of course, the governance of any nation requires people, officials who speak the local language. So there are opportunities, career opportunities, for ambitious people within the Welsh gentry. And so there's one last kind of great national uprising, which is under Owen Glyndwr. Glyndwr. Well, sorry, I'm Henry IV part one-ing,
无论如何，抱歉，继续吧，汤姆，问你的问题。但莎士比亚的处理方式还做了一件事，那就是塑造了哈尔王子（Prince Hal，即未来的亨利五世），他是蒙茅斯的亨利（Henry of Monmouth），他被塑造成一个能够弥合英格兰和威尔士身份认同的人。这是否反映了都铎王朝时期的某种情况？到了那个时候，我们已经有了一个声称拥有威尔士血统的王朝，或者这只是在近似于奥温·格林杜尔叛乱之后才出现的东西？我的意思是，总有现实政治的考量。人们希望在生活中过得更好。奥温·格林杜尔就是一个很好的例子。他曾在伦敦学习法律，从事法律工作。他曾在英格兰军队服役。他的家族与英格兰有联系。就像征服后许多威尔士士绅一样，他开始利用与英格兰的权力结构来为自己开创职业生涯。但有些事情出了问题。他与另一个地主闹翻了，而某种程度上这演变成了一次全国起义。似乎存在着一种对威尔士人待遇的潜意识怨恨。而格林杜尔的叛乱正是利用了这一点，
because he's a figure in Shakespeare's version of Henry IV's reign. That's a terrible portrait of him, isn't it? Because he's like a sort of necromancer babbling in Welsh. He speaks in very florid poetry, doesn't he? Yeah, yeah. Harry Hotspur sneers at him. I don't imagine that's a production. That's a Shakespeare production that's welcomed on the streets of Caerphilly or whatever.
并把人们吸引了过来。而格林杜尔的叛乱正是利用了这一点，并把人们吸引了过来。人们对威尔士所受待遇的那种被压抑的愤怒感爆发成了熊熊烈火。而且这是一场极其暴力、充满攻击性的起义。威尔士的城镇被烧毁，因为它们是英格兰殖民主义的象征，是因为那些关于谁能住在里面的法律。在许多方面，这是一场全面规模的内战。这其中也包含针对英格兰军队的公开战役。这不是一个小事件。而且在许多方面，它在接下来的几个世纪里蹂躏了威尔士的经济。它留下了相当程度的痛苦和愤怒，不仅针对它是如何逐渐平息的，
Anyway, sorry, go on, Tom, ask your question. But what Shakespeare's treatment also does is offer Prince Hal, the future Henry V, he's Henry of Monmouth, and he is cast as someone who can bridge English and Welsh identity. Is that something that is reflective of the Tudor period, by which point we've got a dynasty that claims descent from Wales, or is that approximating to something that does emerge in the wake of Aung Lyn Ddur's rebellion? I mean, there's always the practical politics. People want to get on in life. And Alwyn Glyndwr is a good example of that. He'd learned, he'd plied his trade in the
还针对威尔士人和英格兰人之间的种族紧张局势最终会演变成什么样子。我认为这确实产生了一种感觉：我们绝不能回到那条老路上去了。我们需要重建一个基于合作的未来。是在威尔士人自己内部还是与英格兰王室合作？因为我刚才问到亨利五世时，他率领军队在阿让库尔战役中凭借长弓取得了胜利，而长弓是一种威尔士武器。在15世纪，是否存在英格兰和威尔士身份开始融合的感觉，还是这仅仅是莎士比亚参与其中的一种后期的投射？存在一定程度的和解，威尔士士绅的心态有点像：我们绝不能
law in London. He'd served in the English army. His family had English connections. Like a lot of the Welsh gentry after conquest, he started to make a career of himself with using the structures of power with England. But something goes wrong. He falls out with another landowner and somehow that turns into a national uprising. There seems to be this undercurrent of resentment about the way Welsh people were treated. And Glyndwr's rebellion plays upon that
回到过去，回到格林杜尔时期的那种状态。但英格兰王室同样也抱着：我们不希望再发生一次起义的想法。而且，你知道，在起义被镇压后，它的行动并不是太严厉。你知道，存在着一些和解。甚至向一些社区支付了一些赔偿金。但威尔士弓箭手在英格兰军队中服役这一事实，再次说明，这是更长历史的一部分。这更多是关于个人在某些地方寻找工作愿望的体现。因此，英格兰军队雇佣外国雇佣兵、雇佣外国人的做法并不是什么新鲜事。这并不需要威尔士人和英格兰人之间实现和解，但这正在缓慢发生。
and it draws people out. And Glyndwr's rebellion plays upon that and it draws people out. And this kind of suppressed sense of anger that people seem to have had about the way Wales was treated bursts into flame. And it is an incredibly violent, aggressive uprising. The towns of Wales are burnt because they're symbols of English colonialism, because of these laws about who can live in them. It's full-scale kind of civil war in many ways. There are open battles as well against the English army. This is not a small event. And in many ways, it ravages the Welsh economy for the next couple of centuries. And it leaves a degree of bitterness and a degree of anger as well about the way it fizzled out, but also
但当都铎王朝上台时，你引用了一位威尔士作家奥温·阿普·亨利斯（Owen of Henlis）的话——我发音准确吗？——亨利斯。亨利斯，他称亨利为“将我们从奴役中拯救出来的摩西”。他著名的将自己的儿子命名为亚瑟，即伟大的不列颠英雄。正如我所提到的，他在自己的家族纹章中添加了红龙。那么在威尔士，人们是否有一种感觉：随着都铎王朝的到来，情况真的发生了变化？是的，绝对是。亨利·都铎在许多方面利用了他的威尔士血统。当他为了夺取英格兰王位而向博斯沃思进军时，他利用这一点作为在威尔士获得支持和人力的途径。但一旦他真正拥有了
about how ethnic tensions between the Welsh and the English, what they can turn into. And I think it does create a sense we can't ever go back to that. We need to rebuild a future, which is cooperation. Among the Welsh themselves or with the English crown? Because I was just asking about Henry V, that he goes on to win the Battle of Agincourt with the longbow, which is a Welsh weapon. Is there any sense in the 15th century of English and Welsh identity starting to merge, or is that just a later back projection that Shakespeare's engaging in? There's a degree of reconciliation that the Welsh gentry are kind of like, we must
英格兰王位，他似乎确实兑现了他的一些承诺。他把威尔士人带到宫廷，他做了诸如把龙放到他的纹章上之类具有象征意义的事情。威尔士产生了一种感觉，或者至少在那些撰写这些事情的威尔士人、诗人和领主中间，威尔士已经重新夺回了它在不列颠核心的地位。我们以前的压迫、我们以前的耻辱、我们被征服的感觉，这一切现在都已经是过去了。现在英格兰王位上坐着一个威尔士人，威尔士重新掌控了这座岛屿，就像它本该做的那样。然后仅仅一代人左右的时间，就出现了合并法案。所以在他的儿子亨利八世统治时期。
never go back to this, to what happened in Glyndwr's period. But the English crown is also, we don't want another uprising. And, you know, it doesn't act too harshly after the uprising is crushed. You know, there is some reconciliation. There's even some compensation paid to some communities. But the fact that there are Welsh archers serving in the English army, again, that's part of a much longer history. And that's much more about individuals wanting to find work in some places. So the hiring of foreign mercenaries, the hiring of foreign people by the English army is nothing new. That didn't need reconciliation between the Welsh and English, but that is happening slowly.
所以这是由托马斯·克伦威尔（Thomas Cromwell）推动的，这是他的项目吗？托马斯·克伦威尔的那种——希拉里·曼特尔（Hilary Mantel）会称之为他对英格兰和威尔士的社会民主现代化改造。所以他试图抚平他们关系中的古怪之处，
But when the Tudors come in, you quote a Welsh writer, Owen of Henlis, am I pronouncing that right? Henlis. Henlis, who calls Henry the Moses who delivered us from bondage. And he famously names his son Arthur, great British hero. And as I mentioned, he adds the red dragon to his coat of arms. So is there a feeling in Wales that with the Tudors, things genuinely change? Yeah, absolutely. Henry Tudor exploits his Welsh ancestry in many ways. He uses it as a way of gaining support and manpower within Wales as he's marching towards Bosworth for his battle to seize the English crown. But once he actually has the
建立一些新的郡，把一切理顺。我的意思是，这基本上就是这一切的全部意义吗？是的。我的意思是，有两件事在推动它。我认为，威尔士内部的一些人对此有着一种渴望。因此，尽管都铎王朝现在已经登基，尽管他们正在向威尔士做出象征性的姿态，但我认为许多威尔士士绅仍然觉得他们没有完全获得平等。而且其中一些法律仍然作为背景存在。因此，在威尔士士绅中有一种感觉，他们希望获得与英格兰人平等的法律地位，而《合并法案》就是实现这一目标的一种途径。但在行政管理上，威尔士非常复杂。那里仍然存在边境区，这些地区处于各个英格兰男爵的控制之下。
English crown, he does seem to hold up to some of his promises. He brings Welsh people to court, he does these symbolic things like putting the dragon on his heraldry and things like that. And there is a sense in Wales, or at least amongst the Welsh people who wrote about these things, the poets and the lords, that Wales has retaken its position at the heart of Britain. That our previous oppression, our previous shame, our sense of being conquered, that's all in the past now. Now there is a Welshman on the throne of England and Wales is back in control of this island, just as it should be. And then there are acts of union just a generation or so later. So under his son, Henry VIII.
然后有所谓的威尔士亲王领地，这本质上就是以前独立、后来被爱德华一世的英格兰王室夺取的那部分土地。所以几乎存在两个威尔士。在亲王领地里，威尔士法仍然在使用；而在边境区，情况则是一点英格兰法和一点威尔士法结合，通常根据最适合当地男爵的情况而定。行政管理上非常复杂。而且那里也存在着某种危险感，即它是一个犯罪多发的地方。当然，到了这一时期，宗教问题也开始变得重要起来。天主教和新教之间的紧张关系。随着一个新教国家开始在英格兰崛起，威尔士被视为一种威胁。你知道，我们不能容忍这些不规则的现象。
So this is driven by Thomas Cromwell, is that this is his project of kind of, Thomas Cromwell's kind of, Hilary Mantel would call it his kind of social democratic modernization of England and Wales. So he's trying to smooth out the eccentricities of their relationship
所以这是由托马斯·克伦威尔主导的，这是他的一种宏伟计划，如果用希拉里·曼特尔的话来形容，就是他对英格兰和威尔士的社会民主主义式现代化改造。因此，他正试图抚平他们关系中的种种怪异之处
to create some new counties, to just get everything in order. I mean, is that basically what it's all about? Yeah. I mean, there's two things driving it. There is, I think, a desire for it from some people within Wales. So even though the Tudors are on the throne now, and even though they're making symbolic gestures towards Wales, I think many of the Welsh gentry felt they still weren't fully equal. And some of these laws are still there in the background. So there was a sense that amongst the Welsh gentry that they wanted legal equality with the English and the Acts of Union was a way to achieve that. But Wales was very complicated administratively. There were the marches still, which were under the control of individual English barons.
建立一些新的郡，把一切都整理得井井有条。我的意思是，这基本上就是全部的意义吗？是的。我的意思是，有两个驱动因素。我认为，威尔士内部有些人对此有着强烈的诉求。因此，尽管都铎王朝现在已经登上王位，尽管他们对威尔士做出了一些象征性的姿态，但我认为许多威尔士乡绅仍然觉得他们没有获得完全的平等。而且其中一些法律仍然在背景中发挥作用。因此，威尔士乡绅中有一种愿望，他们希望获得与英格兰人平等的法律地位，《联合法案》就是实现这一目标的一种方式。但是威尔士在行政管理上非常复杂。当时仍然存在边区，这些边区受制于个别的英格兰男爵。
And then there is what was called the Principality of Wales, which was essentially the bit that used to be independent and then got taken by the English crown by Edward I. So there's almost like two Waleses. And in the Principality, Welsh law is still used in the marches. It's a bit of English law and a bit of Welsh law, really, often according to what would suit the local baron. And it was administratively complicated. And there was a sense of danger there as well, that it was a place of crime. But of course, also, by this period, the whole question of religion is starting to become important. The tensions between Catholicism and Protestantism. And as a Protestant state starts to emerge in England, Wales is seen as like a threat. You know, we can't have these irregularities.
然后是被称为威尔士亲王国的地方，这基本上就是以前独立、后来被英格兰国王爱德华一世吞并的那部分土地。所以这几乎就像是有两个威尔士。在亲王国，威尔士法律仍然在使用；而在边区，则是英国法律和威尔士法律的结合，实际上往往取决于什么对当地男爵有利。而且它的行政管理很复杂。那里也有一种危险感，觉得那是一个犯罪滋生地。但当然，在这个时期，宗教的整体问题也开始变得重要起来。天主教和新教之间的紧张关系。随着一个新教国家开始在英格兰崛起，威尔士被视为一种威胁。你知道的，我们不能容忍这些不规则的现象。
And what we can't have as well is the danger of a Catholic invasion coming to England via Wales from Ireland. And of course, that's how Henry took the throne of England in the first place. He invaded England via Wales. So there is an attempt to kind of keep the Welsh on side to give more rights to their gentry, to iron out this complicated administrative situation. And Cromwell was a great fan of doing things, of bureaucracy in many ways. Making omelettes by cracking eggs. Yeah. And now the Acts of Union is seen as this moment of colonialism where Wales is essentially abolished as a separate political unit. Whereas the reality of the 16th century was it was way more complicated than that. It wasn't some attempt to say Wales no longer exists. There's no attempt to ban the Welsh language or anything like that. But well, quite the contrary, isn't it? Because the Bible is translated into Welsh. So that's a hugely significant development. And also, Wales now gets representation in Parliament.
而且我们同样不能承受的是，天主教经由威尔士从爱尔兰入侵英格兰的危险。当然，这也是亨利当初夺取英格兰王位的方式。他是通过威尔士入侵英格兰的。因此，当时有一种尝试，试图拉拢威尔士人，赋予其士绅更多权利，以理顺这种复杂的行政局面。克伦威尔在很多方面非常热衷于做事和官僚体制。就像不打破鸡蛋就做不成煎蛋一样。是的。现在，《联合法令》被视为一种殖民主义时刻，威尔士基本上作为一个独立的政治实体被废除了。然而16th世纪的现实要复杂得多。这并不是要宣称威尔士不复存在的某种企图。也没有人试图禁止威尔士语或类似的事情。但情况恰恰相反，不是吗？因为圣经被翻译成了威尔士语。所以这是一个意义极其重大的发展。而且，威尔士现在也在议会中获得了代表权。
It does get representation in Parliament. And that's symbolically important more than practically important, perhaps, because of course, they're a minority of the MPs at Westminster. And just as today, you know, Welsh voices in Westminster are easily drowned out by English voices. You know, the whole question of the United Kingdom, whether we're talking about this period or today, is the size of England compared to the other constituent nations. You know, English voices will always dominate the conversation. So Wales does get some representation through the Acts of Union. But as you said, the translation of the Bible, which happens a little after the Acts of Union, that's the really important moment, I think, in this period. And that's done with the approval of the English state as a way of ensuring that Wales joins this Protestant revolution and
它确实在议会中拥有代表权。这或许在象征意义上比在实际意义上更重要，因为当然，他们在威斯敏斯特只占议员的一小部分。就像今天一样，你知道，威斯敏斯特的威尔士声音很容易被英格兰的声音所淹没。你知道，无论是探讨这个时期还是今天，联合王国的整个核心问题，都是英格兰与其他组成国家相比的体量大小。你知道，英格兰的声音总是会主导对话。因此，威尔士确实通过《联合法令》获得了一些代表权。但正如你所说，稍晚于《联合法令》完成的《圣经》翻译，我认为才是这一时期真正重要的时刻。这得到了英格兰国家当局的批准，以此确保威尔士加入这场新教革命，
isn't some kind of Catholic outlier on England's doorstep but what it does is give the Welsh language dignity and respect if you can hear the word of God in Welsh if you can pray to God in Welsh if you can be married in Welsh you know these are these are major things in people's lives. And I think today we forget the importance of religion in past societies. Not here. The word of God was everything. And the fact that it's available in Welsh gives the Welsh language status and dignity.
而不是成为英格兰门前某种天主教异类。但这样做赋予了威尔士语尊严与尊重：如果你能用威尔士语听到上帝的话语，如果你能用威尔士语向上帝祈祷，如果你能用威尔士语举行婚礼，你知道，这些都是人们生活中的重大事情。我想今天我们往往会忘记宗教在过去社会中的重要性。这里不会。上帝的话语就是一切。它能以威尔士语呈现这一事实，赋予了威尔士语地位与尊严。
In a world where English was the language of law, it was the language of power, it was the language of politics. English was the language you needed to get on. And that meant it was very easy to portray Welsh as a backwards, uncivilized language. And that did happen a lot. But a language can't be uncivilized if the word of God is written in that language. And so the vast, vast majority of people in Wales are speaking Welsh throughout the 16th century, throughout the 17th century. And then with the 18th century, with the development of industrialisation, then things do start to change. And perhaps we could take a break at this point. And when we can come back, we could look at the coming of the Industrial Revolution to Wales and the impact that that has. I'm Marina Hyde.
在一个英语是法律语言、权力语言、政治语言的世界里，英语是你出人头地所必需的语言。这意味着人们非常容易把威尔士语描绘成一种落后、未开化的语言。这种情况确实经常发生。但如果上帝的话语正是用这种语言书写的，那么这种语言就绝不可能是未开化的。因此，在整个16世纪和17世纪，威尔士绝大多数人都在说威尔士语。到了18世纪，随着工业化的发展，情况才真正开始改变。也许我们可以在此时休息一下。等我们回来时，可以探讨工业革命给威尔士带来的影响。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Look at what these bastards have done to Wales.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦爆料，在我们的问答环节中，我们还会揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、获得独家番外剧集以及抢先购买现场活动门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。看看这群混蛋对威尔士做了什么。
They've taken our coal, our water, our steel. They buy our houses and live in them for a fortnight every year. And what have they given us? Absolutely nothing. We've been exploited, raped, controlled and punished by the English. And that is who we are playing this afternoon. So that's the late Phil Bennett, the great Welsh rugby fly half in March 1977 before a five nations match, which Wales won 49.
他们夺走了我们的煤炭、我们的水、我们的钢铁。他们买下我们的房子，每年只在里面住两个星期。他们又给了我们什么？绝对什么都没有。我们一直被英格兰人剥削、蹂躏、控制和惩罚。而这就是我们今天下午要对阵的对手。这是已故的菲尔·贝内特（Phil Bennett）——伟大的威尔士橄榄球传接球手，在1977年3月五国赛对阵前发表的讲话，当时威尔士以49比...获胜。
And yet, as I imagine you will know, Martin, the irony of that is that just a few weeks later, Phil Bennett and a lot of his teammates joined up with the English to go on the British Lions tour of New Zealand. So that moment actually speaks to exactly what you're writing about, which is the complicated relationship between Wales and England. So that quotation from Phil Bennett, which I could see you smirking while I started to read it because it's very famous in Wales, isn't it? It is. He mentions coal, he mentions water, and he mentions steel. So we've cantered through the medieval period.
然而，马丁，正如我想你所知道的那样，这其中的讽刺之处在于，就在几周后，菲尔·贝内特和他的许多队友加入了英格兰队，前往新西兰参加不列颠雄狮队的巡回赛。所以那个时刻实际上恰恰说明了你正在书写的内容，也就是威尔士与英格兰之间复杂的关系。所以菲尔·贝内特的这段话——当我开始朗诵时，我能看到你在坏笑，因为它在威尔士非常著名，对吧？确实如此。他提到了煤炭，提到了水，还提到了钢铁。所以我们已经大致浏览了中世纪时期。
We've skipped over a little bit of the early modern. And as we approach the 18th and 19th centuries, obviously, coal and steel transform Wales, don't they? I mean, just explain, I guess, to the listeners, because previously Wales had been very, very rural. And then with the Industrial Revolution, it is completely changed. Yeah. If you go back to the middle of the 18th century, Wales is a rural backwater in many ways. It's isolated, it's marginalised. Probably at least 90% of the population only speak Welsh. Some of the gentry are kind of moving to England and have connections. But by and large, Wales is on the periphery of the United Kingdom and economically just not that important.
我们略过了早期现代史的一部分。当我们接近18和19世纪时，显然，煤炭和钢铁彻底改变了威尔士，对吧？我的意思是，给听众们解释一下吧，因为在此之前，威尔士一直非常非常乡村化。然后随着工业革命的爆发，它发生了彻底的改变。是的。如果你回到18世纪中期，威尔士在很多方面还是一个乡村穷乡僻壤。它孤立、边缘化。可能至少90%的人口只讲威尔士语。有些士绅开始搬到英格兰并建立联系，但总的来说，威尔士处于联合王国的边缘，经济上并不是那么重要。
But the Industrial Revolution changes everything because Wales has the right minerals. It has coal in abundance, and not just coal, it has very good quality coal, but it also has the minerals you need to make iron and later on steel. And that changes Wales because suddenly it matters within the United Kingdom. The British government becomes more interested in Wales. It becomes interested in why do they not speak English there? And that question is asked because it doesn't seem to make sense to the English state because to them, English is the language of modernity and progress, et cetera. So how come a corner of our kingdom doesn't speak this language? And because industrialization
但工业革命改变了一切，因为威尔士拥有合适的矿产资源。它拥有丰富的煤炭，不仅有煤，而且是质量极佳的煤，同时它还拥有炼铁乃至后来的炼钢所需的矿产。这改变了威尔士，因为它突然在联合王国中变得重要起来。英国政府对威尔士的兴趣日益浓厚。它开始关注：为什么那里的人不讲英语？这个问题之所以被提出，是因为它在英格兰国家看来似乎说不通，因为对他们而言，英语是现代性与进步等概念的语言。那么，为什么我们王国的一个角落不讲这种语言呢？由于工业化
creates very difficult living conditions, working in coal industry or the iron industry was not a pleasant experience. Yes, the wages were better than living off the land, but the living conditions were very difficult as towns grew up very fast, full of disease, full of overcrowding, etc. So Wales starts to develop a reputation for being unruly. There are a series of riots and protests. The army is sent in on several occasions and opens fire and kills people. And as the English government is saying, well, what are we going to do about this? Attention starts to focus on the Welsh language. And the idea that maybe the problem is that the Welsh people don't speak the same language as the rest of us. And maybe we need to do something about that.
创造了非常艰难的生活条件，在煤炭或钢铁行业工作并非一段美妙的经历。是的，工资确实比靠土地谋生要好，但随着城市飞速扩张，到处充满疾病和拥挤等状况，生活条件变得极其艰难。因此，威尔士开始落下难以管教的名声。一系列暴动和抗议相继爆发。军队数次被派往镇压，开枪并造成人员伤亡。当英格兰政府在说“我们该拿这怎么办”时，注意力开始转向威尔士语。人们开始萌生一种想法：也许问题在于威尔士人讲的语言和我们其他人不一样。也许我们需要为此做点什么。
And that turns people's attention to the question of education. And MPs are saying, you know, it's cheaper to send some schoolmasters to Wales than to hold a unit of army there. Just before we come to education, because this is obviously such a massive thing, just on the Industrial Revolution and the coal and the steel and the huge development of the South Wales Valleys and so on. I mean, obviously, one thing that that does is it creates a great disparity between North and South Wales in a much more marked way than it existed before. But there are some historians, aren't there, who say,
这把人们的注意力引向了教育问题。议员们纷纷表示，向威尔士派遣一些学监，比在那里驻扎一支军队要省钱得多。在我们谈到教育之前——因为这显然是一件如此宏大的事情，单就工业革命、煤炭、钢铁以及南威尔士山谷的巨大发展等等而言——我的意思是，显然，这样做带来的一个结果是，它在威尔士南北之间造成了比以往更加显著的巨大差距。但也有一些历史学家认为，
well, this is basically a purely extractive economy. So this really is a colonial economy. The English are doing to the Welsh what they're doing to so many people around the world. They're just taking their resources and Wales is gaining nothing from this. Is that true? Well, I mean, it is literally an extractive economy because things have been dug out of the ground and sent to other places. It's a complicated one because there isn't a straightforward pattern. Some of the industrialists are English. Some of the early iron masters are English, but they settle in Wales. They become
这基本上纯粹是一种掠夺性经济。所以这确实是一个殖民地经济。英格兰人对威尔士人做的事，和他们对世界上许多其他人做的事如出一辙。他们只是在夺取对方的资源，而威尔士什么也没有从中得到。是这样吗？嗯，我的意思是，这确实字面意义上就是一种掠夺性经济，因为东西被从地里挖出来，然后运到了其他地方。这是一个复杂的问题，因为其中并没有一个单一直接的模式。有些实业家是英格兰人。一些早期的炼铁厂主是英格兰人，但他们在威尔士安家落户。他们成为了
part of Welsh society. Some of them learn Welsh. So it's a little bit misleading, I think, to call them English. In the coal industry, a lot of the big early developments are led by local entrepreneurs, you know, making money, looking for opportunities to make money. Yes, there are English coal owners, but the majority are Welsh. And of course, it's not always easy to distinguish between who is English and Welsh because you have families with Welsh backgrounds living in England, you have English families who settle in Wales where there is some extraction that's that's going on in many ways is in the mineral rights so if you were the local landowner you you were entitled to a share of the profits essentially when somebody dug things
威尔士社会的一部分。其中有些人甚至学会了威尔士语。因此，我认为把他们简单称为英格兰人有点具有误导性。在煤炭行业，许多早期的大规模开发都是由当地企业家主导的，你知道，他们为了赚钱，寻找赚钱的机会。是的，确实有英格兰煤矿主，但大多数人是威尔士人。当然，要分清谁是英格兰人、谁是威尔士人并不总是那么容易，因为有些家族拥有威尔士背景却住在英格兰，也有英格兰家族在威尔士定居。在很多方面，正在进行的开采实际上体现在矿产权上，所以如果你是当地的地主，当有人从你的地里开采出东西时，
out of your ground and a lot of the landowners like people like the Marquesses of Bute, were not local. And money is leaving Wales to go to England via the mineral rights. So industrialisation creates immense wealth, but just as in England, that wealth is very concentrated in a handful of pockets. In many ways, this is a story of class oppression rather than national oppression. Yeah. So I wanted to ask you about that. Wales is historically very much a Labour voting country, and presumably the roots of that lie in the Industrial Revolution. And the dilution of the sense that what is the principal differences between English and Welsh comes to be blurred, and it comes to be between the industrial masses and those who are profiting from their Labour. I mean, in the 19th century, Wales is a liberal
你基本上就有权分享利润。而许多地主，比如比特侯爵（Marquesses of Bute）这样的人，并非当地人。资金通过矿产权从威尔士流向了英格兰。因此，工业化创造了巨大的财富，但正如在英格兰一样，这些财富高度集中在少数几个口袋里。在许多情况下，这是一个阶级压迫的故事，而不是民族压迫的故事。是的。所以我想问你关于这一点。历史上威尔士在很大程度上是一个投票支持工党的国家，想必其根源就在于工业革命。那种认为英格兰人和威尔士人之间存在主要区别的意识逐渐模糊，取而代之的是工业群众与从他们的劳动中获利的人之间的对立。我的意思是，在19世纪，威尔士是一个自由主义的
country. Wales is voting liberal. I mean, of course, it's not a full democracy in that period, but the Liberal Party see themselves as a symbol of Welshness. They promote the rights of non-conformity, and Wales was a chapel-going society, and that was a symbol of difference with England. The Liberal Party celebrate Welsh culture, Welsh language, Welsh history. You know, there is this middle class liberal establishment who are very much pushing a Welsh agenda, celebrating Welsh nationhood. I mean, some historians talk about Wales being reborn in the late 19th century. It rediscovers its history. It rediscovers its sense of identity. And that's part, of course, of European movement. You know, across Europe in the late 19th century, there are national movements and Wales is part of that.
国家。威尔士把票投给了自由党。当然，那段时期它还不是一个完全的民主国家，但自由党视自己为威尔士性的象征。他们倡导非国教徒的权利，而威尔士曾经是一个到处都是小教堂的社会，这也是它区别于英格兰的一个象征。自由党盛赞威尔士文化、威尔士语和威尔士历史。你知道，当时存在一个极力推行威尔士议程、庆祝威尔士民族身份的中产阶级自由派建制派。我的意思是，有些历史学家谈到威尔士在19世纪末期获得了重生。它重新发现了自己的历史。它重新发现了自己的身份认同感。当然，这也是欧洲运动的一部分。你知道，在整个19世纪末的欧洲，到处都有民族运动，而威尔士正是其中一部分。
And Wales is presumably very, very well suited to that because there really is a properly ancient Bardic tradition. And scope for dressing up as Druids is very, very rich and exciting. I mean, some of the traditions are invented. Yeah. But that's what romantic nationalism is all about, isn't it? Exactly. But they're drawing upon something real. Welshness isn't invented. The sense of history, the sense of difference to England is very profound because there was a real cultural difference. Even at the end of the 19th century you know half the population of wales speak a different language to england well that's that's not that long ago that's a massive thing isn't it
而且威尔士想必非常非常适合这种运动，因为那里确实拥有地地道道古老的吟游诗人传统。打扮成德鲁伊祭司的空间非常丰富且令人兴奋。我的意思是，有些传统是后来发明的。是的。但浪漫主义民族主义不就是这么回事吗？确实如此。但他们汲取的是真实存在的东西。威尔士性并非凭空捏造。历史感以及与英格兰的差异感是极其深刻的，因为确实存在真正的文化差异。甚至在19世纪末，你知道，威尔士一半的人口所说的语言都与英格兰不同。这其实并没有过去多久，这是一件非常了不起的事情，不是吗？
the issue of the language and education so so here's the sort of standard version i guess that i had read before i read your book and i guess a lot of people in Wales will tell you, which is that in the middle of the 19th century, the 1840s, Westminster, the directive comes down, stamp out Welsh. Everybody should learn English. Welsh is backward and primitive. And what the famous sort of embodiment of this is this thing that you have to wear around your neck at school called the Welsh knot. And if you're caught speaking Welsh, you put it on. And then the boy who's, or I guess girl, who's wearing it at the end of the day is punished in some way. And people are beaten for speaking Welsh. I mean, I can remember.
关于语言和教育的问题——所以，这大概就是标准版本吧，我想，在我读你的书之前我读到的版本，也是威尔士许多人会告诉你的版本：在19世纪中期，即1840年代，威斯敏斯特下达了指令，要根除威尔士语。每个人都应该学英语。威尔士语是落后和原始的。而这种说法的著名化身，就是你在学校里必须挂在脖子上的东西，叫做“威尔士结”。如果你被抓到说威尔士语，你就得把它戴上。然后到了傍晚，戴着它的那个男孩——或者我想象中是女孩——就会受到某种惩罚。人们会因为说威尔士语而挨打。我的意思是，我还记得……
So my grandfather was Welsh. He had emigrated from Wales, as so many people did, in the sort of early years or middle of the 20th century. He'd lost his accent. He was still very proud to be Welsh. And I remember him saying to me when I was little, we were beaten at school for speaking in Welsh. And I have to say, he was a great teller of tall stories, which obviously does not run in the family at all. So I had my doubts even then. But Martin, your book suggests that this is all a little bit exaggerated and oversimplified. Is that right?
我的祖父是威尔士人。他从威尔士移民出去，就像许多人在20世纪初或中期所做的那样。他已经失去了口音。他仍然为自己是威尔士人感到非常骄傲。我记得当我小的时候他对我说过：我们在学校里因为说威尔士语而挨打。我必须说，他是一个很会瞎编故事的人——显然这并不是我们家族的遗传。所以即使在当时我也心存怀疑。但马丁，你的书表明，这一切其实都被稍微夸大和过度简化了。是这样吗？
Yeah, it's complicated, the history. I mean, definitely in the middle of the 19th century, the British government was worried about Wales. And there is a sense that it is a threat in some ways. And the language being the obvious sense of difference, that's where attention focuses. And commissioners are sent to Wales Wales and they have this big education inquiry that says, you know, Welsh is a backwards language. It's holding the Welsh back from joining civilization. And the sooner the language sort of disappears, the better Wales will be. But actually not a lot actually happens after that in terms of policy, because, you know, the early and the mid 19th century, the British state is very small.
是的，这段历史很复杂。我的意思是，毫无疑问，在19世纪中期，英国政府对威尔士感到担忧。而且人们隐约觉得它在某些方面是一种威胁。语言作为最明显的差异标志，自然成为了关注的焦点。专员们被派往威尔士，他们进行了一次大型教育调查，称威尔士语是一种落后的语言。它阻碍了威尔士人融入文明。这种语言越早消失，对威尔士就越好。但实际上在此之后，在政策层面并没有发生太多事情，因为，你知道，在19世纪初和中期，英国国家规模非常小。
It's not actually doing an awful lot in terms of interfering in daily life in any sphere. There are limited grants available in the education, in the field of education, but by and large, this is a period of kind of laissez-faire politics. The government is hands off. So it has no respect for the Welsh language. It certainly would be happier
它在干预任何领域的日常生活方面其实并没有做太多事情。教育领域有一些有限的资助，但总的来说，这是一个自由放任政治的时期。政府采取的是放手政策。所以它并不尊重威尔士语。如果威尔士语消亡了，它当然会更高兴，但它并没有为此采取什么实际行动。然而在威尔士内部真正发生的是，家长们希望他们的孩子学习英语，因为英语是现代性的语言。你知道，人们环顾四周，发现任何从事不那么累断脊梁骨的工作的人都在说英语。人们明白，英语是摆脱痛苦和贫困的根源。这意味着学校使用英语授课——并非出于威斯敏斯特的某种独裁命令，而是由于当地的压力。它们的存在就是为了教人们英语。问题是：你该如何教一个不懂某种语言的人一门新语言？有些人认为，实现这一目标的办法基本上就是：如果他们说自己的本族语，就狠狠地揍他们。而“威尔士结”——这种如果听到孩子们说威尔士语就会挂在他们脖子上的木牌——几乎就是为了制造一种羞耻感，将说威尔士语与羞辱挂钩。家长们支持这样做吗？家长们似乎确实支持这一点。并没有出现针对这种做法的强烈抗议，而且确实有一些证据表明，这类措施的引入在
if the Welsh language died off, but it doesn't really do anything about that. But what does happen within Wales is that parents want their children to learn English because English is the language of modernity, you know, people look around and they see that anybody with a job that doesn't break your back speaks English. People understood that English was the root out of misery and poverty. And that meant schools, not out of some diktat from Westminster, but because of local pressures, are run through the medium of English. They're there to teach people English. The question is, how do you teach people who don't speak a language a new language? And some people thought the way to do that was to basically beat them if they spoke their domestic language. And the Welsh knot, this wooden board put around people's children's necks if they were heard to speak Welsh. That was to almost create a sense of shame and association between speaking Welsh and shame and being humiliated. Do the parents back this? The parents do seem to back it. There doesn't seem to be any kind of outcry against it and certainly there is some evidence that those kinds of measures are introduced in
某些地方是应家长的要求而进行的。这些地区的绝大多数老师也都是威尔士语使用者。他们是来自社区的当地人。这是威尔士人在对他们自己做的事情。政府并没有这样吩咐他们，但政府赞同这一总体原则。问题在于它不管用，因为这些学校里实际发生的情况是：这些孩子们在学校外面听不到英语，因为社区里没有人说英语。你知道，在乡村威尔士，这些地方完全都在说威尔士语。所以当他们来到学校时，他们通过字面意义上某个人把词语写在黑板上或者发给他们一本书来学习朗读这些词。老师念出那个词，孩子们跟着重复。他们正在学习如何发音这些词。他们正在学习如何进行某种程度的阅读。
some places at the request of parents. And most of the teachers in these areas are Welsh speakers. They're local people from the community. This is something that the Welsh people are doing to themselves. The government isn't telling them to, but the government agrees with the broad principle. The problem is it didn't work because what was literally happening in these schools was these kids don't hear English outside school because nobody's speaking it in the community. You know, in rural Wales, these are entirely Welsh speaking places. So they're coming into school. They've been taught to read these words through literally somebody putting them up on a blackboard or being given a book. And the teacher says the word and the children repeat after them. And they're learning how to say these words. They're learning how to kind of read.
但由于没有人用他们自己的语言告诉他们这些词是什么意思，他们根本不知道自己在读什么。这可不是多邻国（Duolingo），对吧？那么在这种情况下，到底是什么导致了威尔士语的衰落呢？威尔士语在20世纪一直是人们热议的焦点。我认为，关键问题在于移民。工业化创造了高薪工作。你知道，虽然那是严酷的社区、拥挤的社区等等，但归根结底，它们的薪水比靠土地生活要好。因此，人们开始从什罗普郡（Shropshire）、英格兰西南部以及更远的地方涌入工业威尔士。
But because nobody is telling them what these words mean in their own language, they have no idea what they are reading. That's not Duolingo, is it? So in that case, what is it that leads to the decline of Welsh, which has been such a core celebre in Wales in the 20th century? The key issue, I'd argue, is migration. So industrialisation creates well-paid jobs. You know, they're harsh communities, overcrowded communities, et cetera, et cetera. But ultimately, they are better paid jobs than living in the land. So people start to move into industrial Wales from places like Shropshire, the southwest of England, and then further afield.
这在许多方面将英语首次带入了工人阶级社区。现在，最初这些早期的移民会学习威尔士语，因为那是该社区的主导语言。但随着他们人数的增长，他们不再学威尔士语了。而当地人则越来越多地开始学习英语。并且由于他们开始在学校学习英语——特别是当人们发现“威尔士结”不管用，我们实际上需要通过威尔士语作为媒介来教他们英语之后——随着学校教育、教育政策的改善，人们在学校学习英语，然后开始在社区里与这些移民使用英语交流。随着移民的增加，工业社区中的语言平衡，随着移民的增加，语言
And that brings the English language into working class communities for the first time in many ways. Now, initially, those early migrants learn Welsh because that's the dominant language of the community. But as their numbers grow, they stop learning Welsh. And increasingly, local people start learning English. And because they are starting to learn English at school, particularly after people start working out the Welsh not doesn't work, we actually need to teach them English through the medium of Welsh. As schooling, as education policies get better, people are learning English at school, and then they're using English in the community with these migrants. And as migration grows, the balance, the linguistic balance in industrial communities with these migrants. And as migration grows, the balance, the linguistic
平衡在工业社区中开始倾斜。是的。你这里有一些惊人的统计数据。比如：罗达（Rhondda）的人口从1851年的不到1,000人增长到1911年的15万多人。你还谈到了加的夫（Cardiff）的发展，它原本是一个小集镇，最终却成为了——不仅是最重要的工业港口之一，而且是最具多元文化色彩的港口之一。是的。我的意思是，工业把来自世界各地的人们吸引到这里。加的夫在某种程度上拥有整个联合王国中最古老的黑人社区。它位于加的夫的码头区，非常自成一体，与主城区略有分离。当地当局经常对该地区态度恶劣，存在相当严重的种族主义，但工业化确实改变了威尔士社会的整个结构。除此之外，还有一件事：随着英语的
balance in industrial communities starts to tip. Yeah. You've got some amazing stats here. You've got, so the Rwanda saw its population grow from under a thousand in 1851 to more than 150,000 by 1911. And you talk about the growth of Cardiff, which had been a small market town and ends up one of the, I mean, not just one of the most kind of important industrial ports, but one of the most cosmopolitan. Yeah. I mean, industry brings people from, you know, from all over the world and Cardiff has, you know, in some ways the oldest black community anywhere in the United Kingdom. It's very self-contained in the docks area of Cardiff, which are a little bit separated from the main city it's often treated appallingly by the local authorities there's considerable racism but industrialization does change the very structure of Welsh society and one other thing that as well as the English language
到来，一项英格兰运动被威尔士人奉为自己的运动。我很好奇为什么会这样，这一切是如何发生的？这项运动当然就是橄榄球，它现在已经完全与威尔士划上等号了。我的意思是，威尔士显然闯入了足球世界杯，这就是我们讲述这个故事的原因。但实际上，橄榄球一直都是威尔士的传统运动。为什么？这是英格兰公学的一项运动。一些威尔士士绅、一些威尔士中产阶级被送到英格兰的公学就读，并将这项运动带了回来。不仅如此，因为它是英格兰公学的运动，所以它具有一定的社会地位。而且，你知道，
arriving there's an English game which the Welsh adopt as their own and I'm curious why why this and how this happens and that game game is, of course, rugby, which is now absolutely identified with Wales. I mean, Wales are obviously at the Football World Cup, which is why we're doing this story. But really, rugby has always been Wales' traditional game. Why? It's a sport of the English public schools. And some of the Welsh gentry, some of the Welsh middle classes are being sent to English public schools and are coming back with this game. But also because it was the sport of the English public schools and are coming back with this game. But also because it was the sport of the English public schools, it had some social status. And, you know,
当我们思考为什么个人决定用英语而不是威尔士语跟他们的孩子说话时，那是因为英语具有社会地位。这与任何来自英格兰的事物都一样。它带有一种声望。因此人们因为这一点而接受了橄榄球。这项运动传播得非常快，但它很快就成为了威尔士性的象征，因为工业区里有这些来自各行各业的多元化社区。
when we think about why individuals decided to speak to their children in English rather than Welsh, it was because English had social status. And it's the same with, you know, with anything that's coming from England. There's some cachet to it. So people adopt rugby because of that. The sport spreads very quickly, but it very quickly becomes a symbol of Welshness because you have these diverse communities in industrial areas where people have come from all over the place.
橄榄球使他们能够团结在威尔士性的旗帜之下。你是中产阶级还是工人阶级并不重要，你说英语还是威尔士语并不重要，你的家族背景是什么也不重要——许多早期的威尔士橄榄球运动员都是来自英格兰的移民，但他们搬到了威尔士，所以他们穿上了红色的队服和球衣。由于威尔士在19世纪末20世纪初拥有一支非常优秀的橄榄球队，这为其增添了一种情感元素，因为你可不想让你的民族象征成为一样你很不擅长的东西。
Rugby enabled them to unite under kind of the banner of Welshness. It didn't matter if you're a middle class or working class, whether you spoke English or Welsh, didn't matter what your family heritage were a lot of the early welsh rugby players are migrants from england but they have moved to wales so they don the rest and the red shirt and because wales ends up with a very good rugby team in the late 19th century in the early 20th century that adds an emotional element to it because you don't want your national symbols to be something that you're bad at.
正因为威尔士恰好拥有一支实力强劲的球队，它变得极具吸引力。因此，橄榄球成为了威尔士性一个极其强大的象征，它以语言或政治无法做到的方式将人们团结在一起。我认为在整个20世纪，威尔士在足球和橄榄球领域拥有自己的国家队，这是威尔士身份认同能够保持如此强大力量的关键原因之一。
And because Wales happens to have a really good team, it becomes incredibly attractive. So rugby becomes a really powerful symbol of Welshness, which unifies people in a way that kind of language or politics doesn't. And I'd argue that through the 20th century, the fact that Wales had its own national teams in football and rugby is one of the key reasons
嗯，我想问关于这一点，因为有太多内容我们不得不略过了。显然，威尔士出了一位英国首相，一位会说威尔士语的首相大卫·劳埃德·乔治（David Lloyd George）。正如你所说，在过去的一百年里，威尔士在经济上发生了转型。我想当时可能无法预测的一件事，就是威尔士民族主义的复兴。因此，威尔士民族党（Plaid Cymru）在1925年成立。你认为威尔士民族主义的崛起是不可避免的吗？因为它有19世纪的根源，在整个欧洲各地都有发生，比如民族主义政党等等。还是你认为这是一个独特的叙事，因为显然后来建立威尔士新身份的那个经济体系实际上已经注定要消亡了？工业黄金时代其实是一个相当短暂的时刻，对吧？正如你在书中所说，两次世界大战之间的几年对威尔士来说简直是噩梦，在那之后，煤炭、钢铁和所有这些东西就一路走下坡路了。必须做点什么。爱德华八世不是还去访问了那些经济萧条地区吗？所以，民族主义是对这种现状的反应，还是更像爱尔兰民族主义那样，是19世纪各种思想思潮交织下一种不可避免的产品？关于20世纪初的威尔士民族主义，需要记住的重要一点是，它不是政治性的，而是文化性的。它的目标不一定是一个独立的威尔士。它的目标是保护威尔士语。在20世纪20和30年代，威尔士语显然处于衰退之中，部分原因正是我们前面已经讨论过的人口结构变化，但也因为在20和30年代，由于大萧条，威尔士出现了大规模移民。
why Welsh identity has stayed so powerful. Well, I wanted to ask about that because, I mean, there's so much we will have to skip over. So there's obviously a Welsh prime minister, a Welsh speaker in David Lloyd George. As you say, Wales has become economically transformed in the previous hundred years. And I suppose one thing that you might not have been able to predict at that point was the revival of Welsh nationalism. So Plaid Cymru, the Welsh
到了20和30年代，人们开始担心威尔士语可能会在下一个世纪实际消亡。如果我们不采取行动，没有任何事情能阻止这种情况真正发生。因此，民族党（Plaid Cymru）最初的诞生以及威尔士民族主义的最初几十年，并不是关于政治的。它不是为了试图重建威尔士经济。它是为了试图保护语言。事实上，在民族党（Plaid Cymru）的早期阶段，人们甚至对工业抱有一种厌恶情绪。当时有些人甚至说，威尔士的未来应该是倒退回去，重新变成一个乡村农业社会，因为那是威尔士语最强大的时候。直到1945年之后的一段时期，威尔士民族主义才开始发展出这种政治
Nationalist Party, is founded in 1925. Do you think the rise of Welsh nationalism was inevitable because it has 19th century roots, it happens all over Europe, nationalist parties and so on? Or do you think it is a distinctive story because obviously that economy in which Wales has built its new identity is doomed, actually? It's quite a short-lived moment, isn't it the the industrial golden age because as you say in your book the interwar years are dreadful for wales and then after that it's kind of downhill for coal and steel and all these things something must be done the future edward the eighth isn't it visiting the um the depressed areas so is nationalism a reaction to that or is it more just an inevitable like irish nationalism a product of that sort of swirl of 19th century ideas? The important thing to remember about Welsh nationalism in the early 20th century is that it's not political, it's cultural. The goal is not necessarily an independent Wales. The goal is protecting the Welsh language was so clearly in decline by the 1920s and the 1930s, partly because of these demographic changes we've already talked about, but also in the 20s and 30s, there's a mass migration from Wales because of the Depression.
色彩，人们才真正开始争论：我们与威斯敏斯特的关系是什么？我们应该拥有自己的议会吗？我们应该成为一个独立的国家吗？那么就目前而言，就威尔士对自身在英国中的定位以及对“英国”概念的理解而言，现状如何？威尔士保留了非常强烈的自我意识。尽管20世纪初存在种种担忧，但威尔士性确实存活了下来。威尔士语被削弱了，但威尔士性本身存活了下来，因为它并不仅仅建立在语言的基础之上。正如我所说，体育运动是我认为这得以发生的原因之一。因此，威尔士性得以延续。但问题是：这意味着什么？它应该扮演政治角色吗？而且在20世纪的下半叶，
And by the 20s and 30s, people are starting to think the Welsh language might actually die out in the next century. And unless we act, nothing is going to, you know, that's actually going to happen. So, you know, the initial kind of birth of Plaid Cymru and the first couple of decades of Welsh nationalism, it's not about politics. It's not about trying to rebuild the Welsh economy. It's about trying to protect the language. And indeed, in the early period of Plaid Cymru, there's actually an antipathy towards industry. And there's some people saying, actually, the future for Wales should be if we go backwards and we become another rural agricultural society again, because that's when Welsh was at its strongest. It's only in the post-1945 period does Welsh nationalism start to develop this political
随着威斯敏斯特的历届政府未能解决威尔士的经济问题，越来越多的人开始表示：重建我们经济的唯一途径就是把命运掌握在自己手中。尽管在整个时期内这只占少数。甚至直到今天，民意调查显示也可能只有约四分之一的人口支持威尔士独立。但它确实在增长。其中的部分故事在于脱欧，因为人们曾经与之建立情感联系的联合王国，
edge and people start to really kind of debate, what is our relationship with Westminster? Should we have our own parliament? Should we be an independent nation? And so what is the state of play now in terms of that, in terms of Wales' sense of itself in relation to England and in relation to the idea of Britain? So Wales has retained a very strong sense of itself. Despite the paranoia in some ways of the early 20th century, Welshness did survive. The Welsh language was weakened, but Welshness itself survived because it wasn't just based upon the language. And as I said, sport is one of the reasons why I think that happened. So Welshness has continued to live on. But the question is, what does it mean? Should it have a political role? And increasingly, in the second half of the 20th
在很多方面已经不复存在了。尽管威尔士有多数人投票支持脱欧。他们确实投了，但这不一定是因为他们想脱离欧盟，而是因为他们向建制派竖起了两根中指——这是一个让他们失望的建制派。我认为这实际上是对建制派的投票，而不是对脱欧细节的投票。但脱欧同时也表明，重大的宪法变革是可能发生的。10年前，人们还在说“威尔士独立简直是白日做梦”。就在10年多一点前，人们还认为英国将退出欧盟这种想法是极其荒诞的政治幻想。迅速的变革是会发生的。重大的宪法变革是可能发生的。所以对于左翼人士来说，脱欧意味着“我不再喜欢英国了”；对于右翼人士来说，脱欧则表明“其实，也许我们可以独立”。而许多关于脱欧的争论——关于主权、关于照顾好自己、
century, as successive governments in Westminster failed to deal with the economic problems of Wales, increasing numbers of people started to say, the only way to rebuild our economy is to take matters into our own hands. It's a minority throughout the period. And even today, opinion polls suggest maybe only a quarter of the population support Welsh independence. But it is growing. Part of the story there is Brexit because the United Kingdom
关于从底层重建经济——都可以同样应用于威尔士独立和苏格兰独立。我知道身为历史学家——我从个人经验中得知——历史学家对未来的预测简直糟透了。但如果你是一个喜欢下注的人，你认为在我们这一代人或我们孩子这一代人的有生之年，会出现一个独立的威尔士国家吗？还是你认为与英格兰的联合根深蒂固，根本无法拆散？我认为某种形式的联邦制是不可避免的。我不认为联合王国能以目前的形式存续下去。
that people used to have an emotional connection to doesn't exist in many ways. Though Wales, a majority in Wales, voted for Brexit. They did, but not necessarily because they wanted to break away from the European Union, but because it was sticking two fingers up at the establishment, an establishment that had let them down. And I think it was really a vote against the establishment rather than a
但联合王国和威尔士一样，表现出了非凡的韧性。如果它能够改变并适应威尔士和苏格兰对承认和平等的诉求，那么这种情况很可能会发生。归根结底，威尔士的命运将取决于苏格兰的局势。我们做这个节目是因为英格兰今天在对阵威尔士，比赛周围有各种各样的民族主义狂热呐喊。但与此同时，就像橄榄球一样，足球也是如此，英格兰和威尔士的球员彼此非常熟悉。俱乐部和国家队之间的关系非常非常紧密。所以在某种意义上，我想这场比赛确实很好地反映了英格兰和威尔士之间关系的复杂性与矛盾性，
vote for the nuances of Brexit. But what Brexit also showed was that major constitutional change can happen. 10 years ago, people were saying, you know, Welsh independence is a pipe dream. You know, it's not much more than 10 years ago that people were saying the idea that Britain would leave the EU, you know, that would have seen fantastical politics. Rapid change can happen. Major constitutional change can happen. So for those people on the left, Brexit has meant, I don't like the UK anymore. For those people on the right, Brexit has shown, actually, maybe we could become independent. And a lot of the arguments over Brexit about sovereignty, about looking after yourself,
因为这一切并不全都是敌意、民族主义赞歌等等。绝对是的。而且很多事情我们必须持保留态度。当人们高唱爱国歌曲时，并不意味着他们恨自己的邻居。很多时候这在很大程度上就像是一场哑剧。体育运动——尤其是足球——非常类似于此，你知道，威尔士和英格兰的经济紧密相连，威尔士的大多数人在英格兰都有亲戚，我们的社会紧密相连，这意味着两国不可避免地会渐行渐远，即便真的如此，哪怕真的出现了威尔士独立、苏格兰独立，联合王国也依然会
about rebuilding the economy from the bottom up, those are the same ideas that can be applied to Welsh independence, to Scottish independence. And I know historians, I know from personal experience, historians are terrible, terrible predictors of the future. But if you were a betting man, do you think in our lifetime or our kind of children's lifetime, there will be an independent Welsh state? Or do you think the union with England is too deep-seated to undo? I think federalism of some form is inevitable. I don't think the United Kingdom can survive in its current form.
保留其文化和社会的职能，你知道，我们是一个非常小的岛屿，彼此之间的联系太紧密了，不可能完全从对方身上剥离。这是一个很好的结语。现在，有一件事我们还没谈到，我想快速向听众们推荐一下：马丁几年前在BBC第四台（Radio 4）做过一个精彩的节目。主题是查尔斯王子册封为威尔士亲王，对吧？那是节目的切入点。但其中还有一个非常了不起的故事，讲述了一个叫做特雷韦伦（Tryweryn）的地方，那里有一个小村庄被淹没，为了给利物浦市民修建一个水库，这对……利物浦的殖民者来说是一个巨大的推动。——利物浦的殖民者。是的，利物浦的殖民者，完全正确。
But the United Kingdom, like Wales, has proved remarkably resilient. And if it is able to change and to adapt to the demands for recognition and equality in Wales and Scotland, then that may well happen. Ultimately, what happens to Wales will depend on what happens in Scotland. We're doing this because England are playing Wales today, and there's all kinds of nationalist tub-thumping around the game. But at the same time, as with rugby, so with football, English and Welsh players know each other incredibly well. The relationship between clubs and the national teams is very, very strong. And so in that sense, I guess this match does hold up quite a good mirror to the complexities and the ambivalences of the relationships between England and Wales,
这不是一个你经常听到的词。所以那是一个非常棒的节目。对于那些……我想你也许能在BBC第四台找到它。马丁，我觉得它实际上相当感人。我对你的节目赞美得过头了吗？里面有美妙的音乐，非常动人。它可不像《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。
because it's not all just about hostility and nationalist anthems and so on. Absolutely. And we need to take a lot of things with a pinch of salt. When people sing sort of patriotic songs, that doesn't mean they hate their neighbours. A lot of this is kind of pantomime in many ways. Sports, sport football in particular is very much like that you know the the economies of wales and england are very closely related most people in wales have family probably um in england our societies are very closely related and that means that you know it is an inevitable that the two countries will will drift apart and even if they do even if there is um welsh independence scottish independence you know the united kingdom will
这是一个非常震撼的故事，因为这是一个完全说威尔士语的小型社区，他们为了给英格兰修建水库而被迁出家园。这关乎威尔士风景的丧失。这关乎威尔士社区的消亡。但它同时也
retain a cultural you know and and a social function you know we're a very small island and we're all too closely related but you know to completely break away from each other it's a nice conclusion now we didn't one thing we didn't talk about which i would like to quickly advertise to the listeners martin did a brilliant program on Radio 4 a couple of years ago. It was about the investiture of Prince Charles as Prince of Wales, wasn't it? That was the peg. But it also had this amazing story of this place called Treweren, where there was a little village that was flooded to make way for a reservoir to serve the people of Liverpool, which was a huge boost to- The colonialists of Liverpool. Yeah, the colonialists of Liverpool, exactly.
关乎威尔士与英格兰之间的关系，因为大多数（虽然不是全部，但绝大多数）威尔士议员都投了反对票。但它还是在议会中通过了，因为英格兰议员比威尔士议员多得多。现在它已经成为了威尔士文化中的一个标志。威尔士各地都有这样的涂鸦：“记住特雷韦伦”（cofioch drweryn）。人们要求你记住语言的丧失，同时也记住威尔士与英格兰之间的不平等。有人将这种关系形容为“与一头大象同床共枕”。至于它是不是想要压死你，根本重点不在这里。
That's not a phrase you often hear. So that was a lovely programme. And for people who... I imagine you might be able to find it on Radio 4. It was actually really quite moving, Martin, I thought. Am I being too purple about your programme? There was lovely music and very haunting. It wasn't like the rest is history.
这不是一个你经常听到的词组。所以这是一个非常精彩的节目。对于那些……我想你也许能在第四广播电台找到它。马丁，我觉得实际上真的挺感人的。我对你的节目是不是赞美得有点过头了？里面有优美的音乐，非常动听。这跟《历史的剩余》可不一样。
It's a really powerful story because here was a small entirely Welsh-speaking community that were moved from their homes to build a reservoir for England. This was about the loss of Welsh landscape. This was about the loss of the Welsh community. But it was also
这是一个非常震撼人心的故事，因为这里有一个说全威尔士语的小型社区，他们为了给英格兰修建水库而被迫背井离乡。这关乎威尔士风景的丧失。这关乎威尔士社区的消亡。但这也是
about the relationship between Wales and England because most, not all, but most of the Welsh MPs voted against it. But it went through Parliament, because there are more English MPs than Welsh MPs. And now it's become like this badge in Welsh culture. And there's graffiti across Wales that says, cofioch drweryn, remember drweryn. And you're being asked to remember the loss of language, but also the inequality between Wales and England. Some people describe the relationship as being like in bed with an elephant. Whether it's trying to crush you or not isn't the point.
关于威尔士与英格兰之间关系的故事，因为绝大多数——虽然不是全部，但绝大多数——威尔士国会议员都投了反对票。但它还是在议会通过了，因为英格兰国会议员比威尔士国会议员多。现在它已经成为了威尔士文化中的一个标志。威尔士各地都有涂鸦写着“记住特鲁埃林”（cofioch drweryn）。人们要求你记住语言的丧失，还有威尔士与英格兰之间的不平等。有人把这种关系形容为“与大象同床共枕”。至于它是不是想要压垮你，根本就不是重点所在。
Inevitably, at some point, it will roll over and squash you. Well, let's hope that doesn't happen today, eh, Tom? Well, I reserve judgment on that. I actually feel very conflicted about the England-Wales match because I am a quarter Welsh and I always like to root for the underdog. I don't at all. Don't you? You want England to absolutely hammer the Welsh.
不可避免地，在某个时刻，它会翻过来把你压扁。好吧，希望今天不会发生这种事，对吧，汤姆？嗯，对此我保留意见。实际上我对英格兰对阵威尔士的比赛感到非常矛盾，因为我有四分之一的威尔士血统，而且我总是喜欢支持处于劣势的一方。我可一点也不。是吗？你希望英格兰狠狠地痛击威尔士人。
It's funny, actually, because I sometimes think, so the guy who used to run the books pages at the Sunday Times, he was a big rugby fan and an incredibly mild-mannered, sort of tolerant, nice person. And he absolutely loathed the Welsh rugby team. Absolutely loathed them. Andrew Holgate. Yeah, I think it's because he grew up in the 70s.
说实话这挺有趣的，因为有时我想，以前负责《星期日泰晤士报》图书版块的那个人，他是个超级橄榄球迷，性格极其温和、宽容且善良。但他极其厌恶威尔士橄榄球队。极其厌恶他们。安德鲁·霍尔盖特。对，我想那是因为他是在70年代长大的。
And he just said, you know, they used to rub our faces in it year on year. So there you go, Martin. That's a very bleak note on which to end. No, I think we should just re-emphasize that it is, on the footballing level, so much pantomime. It is pantomime, yeah.
他当时就说，你知道的，他们年复一年地把我们的脸按在地上摩擦。所以就这样吧，马丁。以一个非常黯淡的基调来结束。不，我觉得我们应该再次强调，从足球层面来看，这就像是一场滑稽戏。确实是滑稽戏。
Basically. And essentially, they're all friends. So being proud of your country doesn't mean you have to hate anyone else's. Oh, what a nice note. What a lovely note. On that bombshell. Thank you so much, Martin.
基本上是这样。而且本质上，大家都是朋友。所以为自己的国家感到自豪并不意味着你必须讨厌其他任何人的国家。哦，多么美好的一句话。多么温馨的一句话。带着这个重磅炸弹。非常感谢你，马丁。
Thank you, everyone, for listening. And may the best team win bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
谢谢大家的收听。愿实力最强的球队获胜，再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》，想要获取独家节目、抢先收听无广告版以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦猛料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐圈的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想享受无广告收听、独家节目以及优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。